welcome to food flights where I show you
how to make some of my favorite street
food dishes from around the world first
up Boba pancak no that is a first class
flight straight back to Taiwan a few
years ago I went to Taiwan and these
Boba pancakes were on my absolutely
musthave list like this was a fantasy
that I needed to absolutely fulfill but
we could not find it for the life of us
so we're walking around taipe we're
circling the area that it says it's in
finally we asked someone and they're
like oh yeah it's right outside the
building you make a left and then just
circle around and then you know do a
right and then if you turn to the left
and then it's complicated of course it's
a journey to find these Bubba pancakes I
go in I'm like I got to have these Bubba
pancakes and so he brings them out
they're beautiful the pancakes were
fluffy tender buttery that cream with
the Boba every bite was just amazing
cheers catch you on the next Food
fly